well tens of thousands of people are
making their way to las vegas for the
electric daisy carnival happening this
weekend yeah it starts in two days
businesses in the area certainly getting
ready joe muller joining us live near
the las vegas motor speedway with all
those preparations joe
it will be very busy out this well the
pandemic created a few changes for edc
even delaying last year's show now it is
back on at this regular time take a look
at the speedway here at this hour the
finishing touches are being put on edc
and all the 15 stages that are in there
this brings in a lot of people and a lot
of money
over three days 400 artists will take 15
different stages some of the biggest
dj's in edm like tiesto and dylan
francis will be there campers start
arriving thursday morning everyone else
is booking hotels or airbnb's many
spending hundreds of dollars a night edc
is a is one of the events that we look
forward to beau de jardin is the general
manager of this motel 6 at speedway
boulevard in the 15 he is expecting the
crowd we are completely sold out 100
percent booked and
we
plan to be that way over the weekend
ingrid rosa from entertainment labor
force has been setting up for the event
all month she says preps for the event
and today it means a lot of work a lot
of business a lot of
it's hot it's a lot of hours but it's
good money and it's a lot of work for
people that have been just waiting to
work
back out here live now we are two days
away from the vent but people are
already starting to show up that's the
first campers there you could say that
showed up here they're waiting for one
of their friends to get here from
louisiana for the event campers can
start going in tomorrow morning the
first set is friday night friday evening
that is if you're wondering if tickets
are still available well general
admission is actually sold out according
to the edc website but there are some
vip tickets available those are going
for about a thousand dollars reporting
live at the speedway joe mohler live
local now